so what drew you to this role in
interceptor well
well of course i've been always um very
fan of action movies since i've been
little like i've been always like like
really tomboy and i always wanted to be
like be delivered like my friends my
boys have been as strong as the boys and
like it's been like i grew up with
indiana jones and those adventures and
so um i i really would like wanted to do
kind of like these movies and just do
the action and get it really involved so
when they offered me the role that was
just like i was like a dream for me you
know this is a strong independent fierce
woman that never give up so it's just
like it was really really appealing for
me the script and um and also the
challenge to to just
you know to learn and do fights and like
um and kick ass
why not so yeah and then so that that
was like um in the moment they yell for
me i was like yeah i mean i just want to
do it i'm so excited
um and there certainly is a lot of ass
kicking in this movie um how
how much did you have to train
beforehand to get ready for the role
well it was a long process especially
because i wanted to just create that
physicality i really wanted to be strong
like um and
just like to be realistic of like those
i'm so like military girls that that
trained so hard you know so um so we had
like almost like a like six months of
training um and
then like to just like start because
like my my way of training was very
different so it just becomes like a more
military and like
weightlifting and just getting those
arms that i wanted just to
like get like that you could see it um
so then it was
um a lot of diet too that get involved
and then when you start a movie it was
like a lot of fights in the movie so we
have to learn like 800 moves which was
like every like just before like a
couple of months before we had to
just like um every day three hours of
like
like five training and just letting all
that and then going home and just
getting to the gym and do like our like
ritual workout which is like pretty hard
um but but very fun for me very
challenging but it was something that i
just love i love to train so so it was
actually something that i really enjoyed
was this is this the most action that
you've ever gotten to do in a movie yeah
yeah absolutely yeah it's like this is
full on action like it's one fight at
after another
which i've never done um i've been in
all the action movies but like to just
have that um character that is the lead
and has like you know like physicality
agility she has to be very um you know
like really smart in the way she
she she fights and quick and agile um to
just be these big guys in that way so
yeah i've never i've never done that
before
um did you have any favorite stunts
so many yeah i think one of the five
that is like um that i do with which was
like
the stunt coordinator what's it called
ingrid that girl fight it's um unreal
like those like movements and it's just
like even the little length of it and
like it's just like two women that just
don't give up neither of them give up so
i just that pie was one of my favorites
and it's the one i just really need
people
to enjoy
um were there any stunts that you really
wanted to do but you had to turn it over
to the stunt people to do
yeah no that was the opposite like
sometimes they wanted to shorten up
their fights and just take some
movements of them i was like no you
can't take that more with this fight you
can't do that it's like one of my
favorites she's like
um yeah but i mean i i love like um my
cakes it's just kind of my one of my
favorite things
so every time we try to get any kicks of
it i would be like no no you don't no
you're not
we had actually a moment with like with
the director because he's like look at
the lens i'm like trying to shorten up a
little bit and he's like we're gonna
just um this time people just um told me
about it that they just have to just
shorten up and i go so like no wait let
me talk to matt
i ended up convincing him to just leave
it because it was it was it was great
and i do work so hard and you just like
enjoy every time and they're so
different
that um it just becomes like the start
like the moment that you're like no no
no um so yeah no it was actually the
opposite
um can you talk a little bit about
working with matthew riley as a first
time director how did that go for you it
was amazing like i was really impressed
for being my first time director um
you know he's like um an amazing
writer novel writer that you like for
usual thing like an action movie to the
record action movie it's not that easy
even the first time so but he was
amazing prepared he knew everything like
i have my answers for everything um i
i've never seen that his um energy is so
positive like every time that we have
like everything that we show it to him
it's like amazing it's amazing
everybody like everything he was so
happy to be there and like to do this
project that i just like it created an
energy and on saturn with everybody that
you just want to give everything for him
so i we we just laughed so much and and
i enjoyed it so much i think he did some
an amazing job but also he's just like
so prepared he had like he draw
himself like all like every scene almost
of the movie and like he will come with
his own drawings and he will come in the
morning and show him so this is what
we're gonna do today it's like you've
done that it's like yeah yeah yeah it's
just like it was his little drawing that
was very very funny
just having like me you're gonna do this
and that so it was really impressive
yeah it was very impressive what are you
working on next do you have anything fun
coming up so yeah we have a few projects
coming up um i have like a project with
uh russell crowe's called poker face um
and then i have another project called
carmen which is with benjamin mila
pierre
which is um
husband and um
yeah so the two little movies that um
yeah just different totally different
characters
which i'm like um i'm i'm i'm excited
about them well cool well thank you so
much they're telling me to rap so um
thank you very much and the movie was
really fun so oh great thank you i like
it like